[Music]
i'm christopher hine
and this week we're talking about
footwork so what is footwork and aikido
um the last video in this one are a
little bit of a misnomer as far as
specifically doing footwork we're
working on taino hinko now which is
kind of a variation of that it has to do
more though with the relationship
between you and another person or other
people
so in this video we're actually going to
talk about multiple uh
people and how the titanohinka works for
that so how do i vary my position
when there are multiple people involved
in this video we're just going to use
two people
from the two people you could
extrapolate beyond that but quite
honestly once it
gets beyond two people it becomes very
very challenging to position yourself
right
so with two people you can see the clear
ideas and get an idea of
where you should be cutting when you're
in a multiple attacker situation
so i'm going to call josh and mai over
here and we're going to work on the
multiple attacker taino hinko
okay so this week or this today we're
going to talk about
the basic tiny hinko as it relates to
two attackers
now once you understand these concepts
for two attackers you can scale up to as
many attacks as you want it just becomes
harder and harder to see them
and your your goals become more and more
narrow because
it's just difficult to deal with a whole
lot of people so when we have two
attackers like this
we call this position the v position now
the reason is because
they're in a v to me so if you look at
me as being the center and they v
out here like this this is a bad
position probably the second worst
position you're going to be in
now the reason is because these two are
on a flat plane with each other
so they're able to adjust really well to
me every time i move so
if i were for example to take a step
this way josh can come in here a little
bit
and he's kept that b so if i'm trying to
get that way it's really really hard
right
if i'm trying to get over here maya can
cut in on me and she can start to make
that bead this way right so
these guys can always cut around to make
a a wall
that's very difficult for me to get past
now if you look at just me
my ideas are the same right so well i
don't want to be like this
i want to get to a haunted position
right so now it's starting to get behind
me and this leads us to another position
which is called a staggered position now
i'm going to have them go to it just
because it's too hard to move the camera
around right now so i'm gonna have you
guys go ahead and move to a stagger for
me
okay perfect and just take a little step
that way all right so now they're
staggered
so they're not shoulder to shoulder
anymore so they don't have a solid wall
one of them is a little head of the
other one right now i could do that by
either them moving one moves faster than
the other and
they don't stay in a nice alignment
together which is if they're attacking
me that is totally what they should do
is stay
shoulder to shoulder because that makes
it the most difficult for me to deal
with but if i can either trick them into
moving faster or slower to this position
or i could move myself will stagger so
if you look at this right so josh is a
little bit behind to my left and mine is
a little head
on my right so this will give me a clear
direction to move which is that way
but if there was over there in a v so go
back to the v for me there mike thank
you
if they're here in the v and i just
moved myself over i've now achieved a
stagger so essentially i've done the
same thing
josh is a little further back than maya
and we're in that same position so
i can move myself or i can rely on them
depending on if one's moving
faster than the other i'm always going
to have to be judging these two together
now when i'm doing this what i want is
to stack them up so i'm going to have
you guys stack up right in front of me
okay now you guys can't see me which is
great so imagine the camera
was the third attacker you can't see me
so if you were shooting a gun
you would have to shoot josh or maya
before you shot me if you were back in
the day and shooting bows and arrows or
throwing knives or rocks or whatever
you're gonna hit these two guys before
you hit me right so
i want everyone lined up like this i've
given myself an advantage and that josh
cannot do anything to me without doing
it to maya first
he's going to have to change positions
so he'll be using
time going sideways instead of coming
right at me this eye position is what i
want let me go ahead and show you guys
this sideways so for side by side with
each other here
this eye position is fantastic because
what i've done now is i only have
one to deal with i always have an
immediate shield which means i'm always
shielding myself from josh's actions
with maya i can also tie them up and do
all kinds of things to get them to bump
into each other and cause each other all
kinds of trouble
and that's how i want so i'm always
trying to move to this
position if i have two good attackers
you know what they're doing
they're going to try and keep me in a v
until they can get to a better position
we'll show you that one next but
they're going to try and always keep me
in a v to lock me into a corner or
get me in some way i'm always trying to
stagger it which is
equivalent behind me and then stack it
right up into an eye like this now when
i've got an eye i've taken
one attacker out of the play essentially
right so i've kind of taken josh out for
a second i'm always giving him trouble
with maya
now they're of course always going to
try to be working out of this if we were
here josh wouldn't stay here very long
he would move now if josh moved that way
i would try and move this way to again
stagger that line right
if josh are to make that eye if josh
came this way so he's created a stagger
i'm going to begin moving this way and
stack them back up i always am trying to
stack up multiple attackers with two
it's pretty easy to see as it becomes
three or four attackers it becomes
really really hard you've got to be
doing a lot of micro adjustment real
quick but that's the idea that's what
i'm stacking
now if i had these two and a v over here
and they were a lot better at this than
me right so i mean these two are working
together
and if if the school starts working if
your school starts working towards not
the idea of
uke is supposed to take all the falls
but the uke has got an objective that
objective is to get nage
then you'll start seeing people start
playing together much better and these
two will get good
at staying side by side like that until
they get me into a corner
now what they really want is this
position this is the trap position
now i cannot deal with them both at the
same time right i guess i can
jean-claude van damme or something you
know like maybe you know if i got the
moves i get one of those guys right i
can do all kinds of stuff maybe
but that's a silly fantasy right in
truth i'd be hitting maya and then
joshua would attack me or i turned and
hit josh
and maya would attack me and this sucks
right back and forth back and forth back
and forth
they're gonna get me this way i cannot
afford to be in a trap position like
this
which is where they're always trying to
get me they're always trying to work me
into a trap like this
now understand that you should never
willingly put yourself in a trap so if i
have these two here
when maya our side and maya and josh are
side by side like this
if they were to stick their arms out to
their sides you can see i have no escape
room
right so if i try to shoot through this
and they're paying attention they're
going to immediately get me because
their arms can go out to the side
i can't shoot through the middle unless
one of them is facing away
or their arm distance is so great
perfect
that i can freely get through this area
right and even this is still a little
dangerous so i really want to avoid
traps at all costs so when i see two
attackers coming for me
i generally don't want to shoot up the
middle now with all things there are
exceptions to the rules and times where
you can get away with this and and i
love to exploit these times because when
you're working with two cases sometimes
you can really trick them good with it
but as a general rule and especially
when you're just beginning to work with
multiple attackers you can't shoot
through the middle that's a trap
position
the reason it's a trap is because once
i'm here i can't deal with both these
guys at the same time it's going to be
in a bad position we have to learn nina
and dory from here so
we'll get to those techniques but it's a
bad position for me so real quick i'm
going to review the basic ideas we have
so this is a v
if they were to be staggered
this is a staggered position right with
my little back josh a little forward
they could also put me into an eye or i
could put them into an eye either way
this is where they're both lined up
which is good for me that's the best
position or i could be in the worst
position
which is to be in a trap here in the
middle these are the basic multiple
attackers
or tiny hinko that we use in aikido at
this school anyways i'm christopher hine
thanks a lot for watching